[Music]
this episode of the Tim Farriss shows
brought to you by linked in the write
higher can make a huge impact on your
business the wrong hire can create your
business and I have seen example after
example from thousands of my readers at
a minimum where they've told me stories
of how finding the right person at the
right time and in some cases not even
asking what should I do but asking who
should I find because that person can
help me determine what exactly to do
more intelligently and I've had a chance
to hire two such people in the last year
and that has just made my business take
a quantum leap forward and my complexity
in my personal and business life get cut
dramatically and this type of
simplification cannot be overvalued we
think a lot about hiring and I think a
lot about hiring and it is a skill that
I've had to learn it is important to
find the right person but where do you
find that person you can post a job on a
job board and hope that that right
person finds your job that they are on
the Internet happening to scan something
here and there and then find you but
think about it how often do you hang out
on job boards the answer is probably not
very often so don't leave finding
someone great to chance when you can
post your job exactly where people go
every day to make connections grow in
their careers and discover job
opportunities that is linked in most
LinkedIn members haven't recently
visited the top job boards but 9 out of
10 members are open to new opportunities
and with 70% of the US workforce on
LinkedIn posting there is the best way
to get your job opportunity in front of
more of the right people and you can be
very very highly targeted and specific
people who are qualified for the role
you
and ready for something new this is
where you find them it's the best way to
find that person that key person who
will help you grow your business and
this is why a new hire is made every 10
seconds using LinkedIn that's bonkers
every 10 seconds so head to linkedin.com
forward slash Tim and get $50 off your
first job post that's a linkedin.com
forward slash Tim TI m to get $50 off
your first job post LinkedIn comm
forward slash Tim take a look
terms and conditions do apply this
episode is brought to you by peloton
which I've been using probably for about
a year now peloton is a cutting-edge
indoor cycling bike that brings live
studio classes right into your home you
can also do on-demand which is what I do
we'll come back to that so you don't
have to worry about fitting classes into
a busy schedule or making it to a studio
or gym with a hectic or unpredictable
commute I for instance have a peloton
bike right in my master bedroom at home
and it's one of the first things I do
many mornings I wake up I meditate for a
bit then I knock out a short 20 minute
ride in my undies hard to do that at the
gym take a shower and I'm in higher gear
for the rest of the day it's really
convenient and has become something that
I look forward to so you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
live with thousands of other riders
across the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip-hop rock and roll or say
low-impact versus high intensity or
interval you can pick the class
structure and style that works for you
and in my case I quite like Matt wolbers
and I tend to do on-demand and listen to
a lot of and watch many of the same
classes over and over but I'm kind of
promiscuous and also enjoy classes from
a lot of the other instructors they have
peloton an amazing roster of incredible
instructors in New York City with a
whole range of styles and personalities
so you can find what you're in the mood
for you also get real-time metrics that
you can use to track your performance
over time and that will help I would say
catalyzed you to beat your personal best
now that all sounds good right
gamification yadda yadda yadda I
think that it would work for me or in
any way incentivize me but they really
100% hit the nail on the head I was very
very impressed with how motivating it
was I know work tremendously to keep me
pushing which quite honestly takes a
fair amount I can get quite lazy
particularly with anything that edges on
endurance which is kind of more than
five reps of anything for me so check it
out
discover this cutting edge indoor
cycling bike that brings the studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
calm that's o-n-e
peloton PE l oto and.com and enter the
code Tim all caps at checkout and get
$100 off of accessories with your policy
on bike purchase so get a great workout
at home anytime you want check it out go
to one peloton calm and use the code Tim
to get started why hello there
you sexy little minx 'iz minx is it
murder of crows a gaggle of geese I
don't know this is Tim Ferriss welcome
to another episode of the Tim Ferriss
show where it is my job to interview an
attempt to deconstruct people who are
excellent world class at what they do my
guest this episode is Susan Cain she's
been very widely recommended widely
requested by all of you and here she is
Susan is the author of the bestsellers
quiet power subtitle the secret
strengths of introverts and quiet
subtitle the power of introverts in a
world that can't stop talking the latter
of which has been translated into more
than 40 languages quiet is also in its
seventh year on the New York Times
bestseller list that is a long time and
it was named the number one best book of
the year by Fast Company magazine which
also named Kane one of its most creative
people in business she is the chief
revolutionary of quiet revolution and
her writing has appeared in the New York
Times the Atlantic The Wall Street
Journal and many other publications her
record smashing TED talk has been viewed
more than 20 million times and was named
by Bill Gates one of his all-time
favorite talks you can find Susan on
Twitter at Susan Cain CAI N
at the website quiet rev.com and on
facebook under author Susan Cain so
without further ado please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with Susan
Cain Susan welcome to the show thank you
so much for having me I have been
looking forward to having you on the
show for some time and we have a lot of
terrain to possibly cover so we may end
up having a part two and three but I
don't wanna get ahead of myself I
thought that we could look at public
speaking just for a second because many
people will associate you with this
blockbuster mega-hit of a TED talk and
rumor has it that you straight in the
delivery room from the get-go or a
natural-born killer on stage this is
true
were you born a spectacular public
speaker oh my gosh okay well everybody
listening you can't see Tim right now
but he has a very devilish smile on his
face because of course the answer is the
complete opposite so I had a lifelong
while dating back to middle school I
know exactly when it started I had an
almost lifelong fear of public speaking
and a lot of people say they're afraid
of public speaking and you know they're
telling the truth but like they didn't
have a fear the way I had a fear of it
it was it was so extremely what was the
triggering event oh okay the triggering
event was I had recently switched to a
new middle school and I was in an
English literature class and I probably
appeared to the teacher in that class to
be not a shy person at all because I
love English so I was always
participating so anyway she called me up
to the front of the room we were doing
Macbeth and she called me up with a
friend of mine and she said okay you're
gonna play Lady Macbeth and your friend
Rob is gonna play Macbeth and just
improvise the scene and for me as a shy
person in a new school this was like
total kryptonite and I couldn't say
anything I just completely blanked out
and just stood there dummy at the front
of the class and finally just had to
kind of sit back down red-faced not
having said a word and it says to her my
god make my palms sweat just listening
to it yeah yeah you know and I and I
know this now now that I've studied all
this stuff that if you have an
experience like that it gets encoded
into your amygdala which is the part of
your brain that that registers all your
fears and then the amygdala for the rest
of your life is doing its job by saying
oh you know I'm gonna steer you clear of
any situation ever approximating
anything like that literature class ever
again so after that anytime I had to
give a speech and I did it you know I
used to be a lawyer and on Wall Street
and stuff anytime I would do it I would
just sort of suffer my way through and I
would always lose five pounds because I
couldn't eat before like for a week
before so then then I started writing
this book quiet and at this after I had
left law and I really really really
cared about it you know it was my dream
come true to be a writer and I cared so
much about the ideas in the book and I
didn't want my fear to stand in my way
and I was giving this TED talk so I had
to overcome it how did he start it
started but sure now that I've had a
cappuccino as longtime listeners know I
tend to to jump a lot how did the
opportunity for the TED talk come about
so I had a friend who worked at Ted and
told him about the book and he kind of
passed on the idea to the curators at
the time and I think that they
understood that most of the Ted audience
is really introverted and so they knew
that it would relay it with their
audience and I think that that was
probably why they invited me in and and
I mean I'll come back to how I overcame
my fear in a minute but I will tell you
he turned out to be so accurate that
after I gave the talk you know I came
down off the stage and I was absolutely
mobbed for the whole rest of the week by
every single other audience member who
were all coming to tell me you know
that's my story too
I'm going around pretending to be this
very confident extroverted person and
that's not really who I am so amazing
yeah yeah present company included right
oh yeah absolutely I mean I went to I
will I will steer us back and you will
Britain also bring us back to what we
were just talking about last night at a
group dinner which I helped organize
keep in mind at a wonderful restaurant
here in New York City called the Lilly
it's a Lebanese place I had to take four
or five bathroom breaks which were not
to use the bathroom it was joy that is
what I do at any dinner of more than one
or two people I have to exit not just
the conversations but the environment to
just recharge my batteries and gather my
bearings for a few minutes I need to go
back up it's like you're feeling a kind
of overstimulation addition yeah
stimulation yeah I mean that's so
interesting because I've heard you talk
before about moving to Austin and having
these group dinners and I thought oh
that's so interesting that that's what
Tim wants to do because like I would
never choose to socialize that way I
always love to socialize one-on-one like
almost the way we're doing right now you
know sitting here just talking there's a
there's a there's a kind of boiling
point for me in terms of size like four
to six I can handle it depends it
depends for me also on the environment I
think more so than the number of people
so when I do these group dinners I will
generally host them at home or have them
at one of my friends homes rain not in a
popular restaurant yeah like I said last
night so I'm just gonna say what's
interesting about that is how strategic
you are about it and I really noticed
this with people so we were just talking
about Ted I was just talking to Chris
Anderson who runs tan about this whole
phenomenon and he describes himself as
an introvert to you and he said he loves
group dinners if he can if there's a
specific topic that everybody is
gathered there to discuss and he knows
it's gonna be something really
substantive then he's in his comfort
zone you know but if it's just kind of
this amorphous socializing he wants to
leave I so just on the
the tactical practical side I also tend
to very frequently cook the meal for the
group so that I have a task yeah while
people are arriving and talking also
deliberate because I'm often inviting
people who don't know one another so I
wanted them to have a chance to chat
without having me as a mutual crutch if
that makes sense yeah but in any case
[Music]
that's a really good strategy I heard
that for many people no but I I eat I
can play extrovert I can I'm good at
playing afterward but up until say sixth
grade I wouldn't even go out to recess I
would sit on a step and read usually
books about sharks and fish because I
wanted to be a marine biologist but I
wouldn't even go out to recess Wow it's
it's a lot of what you talk about and
have written about certainly strikes a
chord now I feel like I want to ask you
so many questions we talked about
could go back and talk to sixth grade
you right this minute
like would 6th grade you have any idea
that you would have the life path that
yours has taken but that's so public
absolutely not no definitely definitely
not I mean what happened in sixth grade
also just for people who might be
wondering what happened in sixth grade
if it's up until sixth grade what
happened in sixth grade or I should say
more accurately the summer of fifth
grade is that I had a huge growth spurt
and I had been bullied really badly I
was born premature and very small and I
was bullied really really badly up until
the end of fifth grade then I left to a
summer camp and gained about 30 pounds
of muscle and grew four to five inches
over the summer came back and then like
Captain America yeah yeah exactly and
then the bullies who had been accustomed
to bullying me tried their usual
playbook and I just went on this
vigilante spree like The Punisher and
that changed the dynamic so I was able
to actually go outside and do things
that I wanted to do recess from that
point on so it didn't mean that I
socialized a lot more but I
more mobility is that it that is what
happened but like you and this part of
the reason why I wanted to start with
this question about overcoming a fear of
public speaking is that it's when people
see the finished product it's easy to
assume that it comes from an attribute
as opposed to a skill yes and in fact a
lot of what appears to be natural
appears only to be natural because it
started off very very unnatural and
someone has worked a chipping away at it
over time I think that's true I think
almost so often when you see someone
who's really good at almost anything
it's because they actually started out
exactly the opposite and then they cared
so much about fixing that problem yeah
so and but in terms of how I overcame
that fear and I I have this kind of
evangelical desire to share it because
it was so extreme I feel like if I could
do it then I know any way I could can
overcome any fear so first of all I
spent years sitting in therapists office
offices kind of cozily discussing well
what might be the sources of this fear
and you know what do i trace it back to
you and and like that and and that does
no good at all i I'm actually a big
believer in therapy but not for this
type of issue so what really does it if
you're afraid of something you can't you
have to you have to expose yourself very
slowly to the thing that you fear in
really manageable doses so you can't
start off by giving the TED talk so in
my case I signed up for the seminar and
it was a seminar for people with public
speaking anxiety I was here in New York
and you know you'd get there and on the
very first day all you had to do was
stand up say your name sit back down
declare victory you're finished and
that's it what was the organization oh
gosh Toastmasters or something no and I
am a big fan of Toastmasters but this
was almost like more remedial than
Toastmasters light
this is like free Toastmasters yeah so
the guy's name he's amazing his name is
Charles de cogno and you can find his
organization it's a speakeasy calm and I
think you're spelled with three E's
perfect I'll put a link in the show
notes for people as well yeah yeah I
really recommend him
yeah and so you know you'd come back the
next week and maybe you'd stand up and
and he would do these things like he'd
have people stand on either side of you
so you didn't feel all alone up there on
stage
it's brilliant yeah yeah and then the
audience would ask you questions like
where are you from and where do you go
to college you know some really easy
stuff you answer the questions and
you're done and it's like if you do that
little by little by little you actually
really can overcome it it's kind of
crazy but true but I will say having
said all this still you know there's
something about a TED talk that's on
some whole crazy other realm of public
speaking nerves even if the setting is
exactly the same there is a performance
anxiety associated with that
three-letter acronym for sure
yeah we were talking about this before
we started taping though you know so
many of the speakers are really
practiced on stage and yet you see them
when it's before they go out and they're
sweating bullets and they're all losing
it yeah we were chatting for a second
about and Chris Anderson could certainly
correct me I'm blanking the exact term
but there's some space right next to the
stage behind the curtain called the Zen
room or the relaxation cube there's some
very pleasant sounding name for this
space and it's intended to be the the
the next up a batting cage for the the
two or three speakers to come and I
remember it's probably 15 or 20 minutes
before I was supposed to go alive or no
it couldn't have been that was probably
an hour before and I really didn't want
to be around a lot of people and in the
green room there are all sorts of staff
and lots of people milling around
and working on production and I thought
to myself I need to go to the Zen room
we'll just call this end room and so I
walk out to this end room and I won't
mention names but they're like three
just killers these are consummate
professionals who have done this type of
thing thousands of times people I look
up to and would love to someday have a
coffee with and they're freaking the
[ __ ] out I was like not helping not
helping I need to leave the Zen room
right now yes it's a different beast so
then how do you go from talking about
your favorite color onstage with two
people next to you
to Ted that right okay so I graduated
from that to Toastmasters which I also
completely recommend and should I
describe what that is yes please yeah
okay
so Toastmasters it's a worldwide
organization you can absolutely find one
near you because they're everywhere and
and it's basically this nonprofit thing
where you sign up for you sign up for a
group that meets near you and once every
two weeks you get together and you
practice public speaking together and
they have this this ritualized way of
doing it and some of the time you're
practicing speaking off the top of your
head and sometimes it's a prepared
speech and it's just kind of giving you
that exposure therapy of you know
putting you in the Beast of the thing
that most frightens you you have to show
up every two weeks and do it so I did
that but then the next day after that
and it was my husband's idea was I hired
a coach for the full week before the TED
talk that was really amazing guy named
Jim Fife who I also completely recommend
and since then he has coached many other
Ted speakers so I worked with him
morning till night for a full week
before the talk for you yeah and what
did the working with him look like okay
so he he did a really brilliant thing he
was very psychologically attuned and I
said to him you know I am really
comfortable in general talking to people
one-on-one and kind of like cozily
sitting on a couch and talking about
life I love that
it's for me at that point though getting
up on a stage and holding forth was the
hard thing so he said okay let's
practice your talk sitting on the couch
and just talk to me about it and we did
that for like two days and it was only
after that that we then moved to the
stage and started getting into kind of
the theatrics of it it was brilliant and
that really that that kind of transition
was so helpful I just want to note that
this is I spent so much time with it I'm
so obsessed with good teachers yeah
good coaches this is very common where
they will let effectively say let's
start from where you are right now right
and they will they will always return if
they sense any type of overwhelm or if
you were to bring you back to a point of
familiarity or comfort yeah and then
edge into sort of the next concentric
circle of yes yes your limit of comfort
yeah and I think they also have to show
a lot of non judgement because I had
some dark moments during that week you
know for me this was the abyss and I was
just hanging out in the abyss for a week
and so he saw me you know I had only
just met him and he saw me not in the
most flattering circumstances and yet I
didn't feel embarrassed by that did you
anything in the beginning to assess you
or establish a baseline or was it more
of an interview that he used like an
intake do you remember what it wasn't
really a formal like that you know he's
such a human guy it was just like we
were just talking you know yeah yeah
yeah
disguised as intakes Merriman Smith
Smurf oh yeah and then so the amazing
thing to me now is I now super
ironically have a career as a public
speaker like I traveled the world going
and giving talks to other companies and
conferences all over the place I mean I
got it like I asked you if we could tell
sixth grade to him where he would be
what would he say and I say that to
myself too like if you could have even
told me eight years ago
that this would be my life I would have
been so shocked by it and now I've come
to like it
do you have any particular pregame
ritual or anything that you did in the
hours leading up to your talk that
helped or that you didn't do I have
things nano back then I just suffered
but what do you have now now I have a
few things I mean I do deep breathing
just like everyone else I'm sure you've
heard that a million times but it's got
to be real deep breathing you know where
you really feel your belly in your
diaphragm filling up but for me what I
also do is I usually think to myself and
I do this especially when I'm speaking
to an audience that I find more
intimidating you know like a group of
finance people at an investment bank or
something um I will say to myself there
I am sure is one person in this audience
who has a child who is shy or
introverted and if that child has a
better life because of one tidbit that
that person hears today then it's all
good and that pulls me out of myself
instantly it's a yeah it gives you also
a hurdle that you can clear for winning
the presentation so to speak yeah right
it's a manageable goal but I think it's
it feels deeper than that to me it feels
also like I think when people get
nervous about speaking you know that
obviously they're really nervous about
being judged right but this completely
shifts the energy where it's not any
longer about how anybody judges me it's
about can I help that kid out there and
I I want to say also that part of the
reason I am more than happy actually
excited to spend so much time talking
about this is that it is not specific to
public speaking right this just happens
to be a very common fear and perceived
weakness of many many many people also
yeah as a side note what Warren Buffett
says is his greatest ever investment I
put more specifically a Dale Carnegie
course that he took in public speaking
right right
has it magnified his ability to do
almost everything else communicate
effectively both in spoken word but also
in the written word and yeah some
respects yeah go ahead
I was just gonna say that I've never I
don't think I've ever spoke about this
but I also did Toastmasters and if you
have trouble finding it oftentimes there
are large companies that will have
within their HQ or any large location
their own Toastmasters group and that's
actually how I found it in San Jose
initially it was at Adobe so I would go
in and I would do this Toastmasters and
your your description of having this
very logical progression of small wins
layered upon small wins getting up on
stage and then getting offstage right
getting up on stage having two people
next to you and answering a few
questions and getting offstage is so
incredibly effective and I I'm laughing
right now because I remember when I was
preparing for my first presentation at
South by Southwest so this is a very
large festival and conference in Austin
Texas in the timing was 2007 it's about
um I want to say a month month and a
half before my book is going to come out
my first book which I'm very nervous
about
there had been no speaking slots but I
had pitched Hugh Forrest at the time who
I'd been introduced to that I would I
would take anything available corner of
a room hallway if there are any
cancellations I would really appreciate
the opportunity to speak at the event
and lo and behold there was a
last-minute cancellation not by a
keynote speaker but by a sponsor who was
going to have a stage to pitch their
products from and in this makeshift cafe
and I was like I'm in I'm in but I was
so incredibly nervous about this that in
the beginning in particular I was and
this is true today
too nervous to practice my rough
draft of the presentation in front of
people yeah okay and so what I did I was
I was staying in a guest bedroom at a
friend's house he had three chihuahuas
and I and I went outside as playing the
chihuahuas and they followed me into the
garage I was I practice in the garage I
didn't want to practice in the house
where my friend's wife was and I gave my
presentation I felt reasonably confident
about the content but I wasn't
comfortable with any of the performance
aspects of trying to keep attention so I
gave my draft of this talk over and over
again until I could get the dogs to sit
and stare at me somewhat bewildered but
to hold their attention and that was
that was the litmus test for me Wow to
graduate to giving a rough draft in
front of humans for those people out
there who are wondering whether this
this all comes naturally to me it does
not at all have you talked about that
before or is this the first time I think
I don't think I've talked about that
certainly I don't think I've talked
about it all in the podcast and the TED
talk also something I did which I did
not do for the South by talk which I
thought really made a difference was I
practiced giving the talk in front of
small groups of strangers once I had a
reasonably polished version and I asked
friends of mine who worked at larger
companies who had teams during lunch
hour if there was if there happened to
be an empty conference room could they
invite people to hear a rough draft of a
TED talk and then I would ask them for
feedback and usually there was enough
time that I could give it two or three
times so I can actually incorporate
their feedback give another version and
once I'd given the second version there
are a lot more people in the room who
are willing to be critical right the
first round you get wanted to yeah and
then the this is just something I've
thought about a lot because I've been so
nervous about public speaking for so
long and in it by the way it doesn't
really go away like I at least for me I
still have those nerves but with Ted
very specifically I assume
and this came from sports but I'd never
applied it that I was going to be my
heart rate was probably gonna be 30
beats per minute higher than normal and
that it was not just important for me to
practice the content but to practice
under the physiological stress that I
would probably experience when trying to
deliver the content so I would do a
bunch of push-ups in another room and
drink I got two double espressos and
wait for it to hit and then go in and
give my dress rehearsal to see if I
could handle that stimulation that was
so so smart and you know listening to
that story is reminding me of this
crucial step that I left out in a lot of
ways a kind of mistake that I made which
is you know I told you I worked with
that guy
Jim for a week who was amazing and I
thought I was pretty well ready at that
point so I talked to my friend Adam
grant who's a very dear friend very good
speaker - and a really good speaker and
who also started out as a very nervous
and by his description a terrible public
speaker he says he used to get terrible
reviews from his students and he just
worked and worked and worked and at it
and now he's the most popular professor
at Wharton but ok so I was talking to
Adam about all this and so he said so
I'm leaving for Ted on Sunday morning
right to fly out to California which is
where it was at that time and he says oh
I'm gonna pull together a group of
friends and you can practice your talk
in front of them and so this is Friday
night and I'm leaving Sunday morning and
so I show up at this apartment full of
Adam and his friends and I think that
I'm pretty well done with the talk and
this is the first time that I'm giving
it in front of any kind of group because
I didn't have the foresight of what you
just described and not only was I so
nervous but I realized from the feedback
that a lot of the content was all wrong
and it's Friday night and I'm leaving
you know like the next day basically or
the day after the next day so I went
home and I just spent the whole entire
night rewriting the whole final third of
the talk and then I'm like on the plane
going out to Ted trying to
memorize the new talk I don't recommend
kind of approach but you need to get
real people in front of you this is just
like entrepreneurship and people try to
get the product perfect before exposing
it to any prospective client that you
really need to get into the messy
reality of a live audience or a real
customer looks like and the same was
true for me I made a lot of changes in
the last few days which I thought were
just gonna be fine-tuned right and then
you find Jenny and I was like oh
actually I really need to come I need to
completely change by 30% of this yeah
and I was very very nervous before the
TED talk and I came offstage and I did
not think that I I didn't I didn't think
that I blew it but I didn't think that I
I did a great job I came off stage
thinking that there were definitely bits
and pieces I could have done better but
worked out seems to have worked out okay
wait but I want to come back to one
thing that you said from the benefit of
people who are listening now so you said
that you still are really nervous when
you give a talk no I mean are you really
as nervous as you used to be because I
really want people to understand that
like you can get to a point you might
still have butterflies it's not like the
nerves completely disappear but they get
to I in my experience and from all the
literature that I've studied on this
they really do get to a point where you
can manage them and the difference
between manageable and non manageable is
gigantic in terms of its effect on your
life and your career and everything so I
just want to make sure I can clarify so
yeah I depends a lot on the event right
so if it's we're gonna do a Q&A and it's
a friend of mine interviewing me on
stage that's not from my perspective
really public speaking I mean it is but
at this point I could do that with zero
preparation if it's anything resembling
a keynote if it is Tim on stage talking
to an audience and they expect something
that has been well rehearsed
my physiological response is still very
strong I get really sweaty hands i pace
i have very minimal contact with with
anyone beforehand but let me mention a
few a few things number one and I both
Mike Tyson and Dean Martin used to vomit
before nearly every performance but the
way that they psychologically contended
with that evolved over time and what
well since I mentioned Mike Tyson cus
D'Amato who was the trainer who really
in a lot of respects I think boxing
boxing scholars or boxing fans would
agree made Tyson into what Tyson was at
his prime as as an athlete used to say
something along the following that the
the here and the coward feel the same
thing it's how they respond yes oh I so
believe that yeah and I mean there is no
courage without the presence of fear
mm-hmm and for me I have come to see
those physiological symptoms that used
to make me panic that used to make me
feel like I was doing something wrong
that used to make me feel like I was
unprepared as simple precursors to a
performance the way that I frame them
for myself is completely different and
I've learned to view it as this
energetic asset that I can use yeah and
that has made all the difference and it
has decreased in some circumstances but
certainly before Ted I mean I had given
hundreds of different presentations and
it was like I was getting on stage for
the first time in part also for people
who don't know they are very as they
should be strict about many things at
Ted including running over oh yes if
you're running overnight and I want to
say and this is exactly what they should
say but in effect they say if you run
over
by you should not run over number one do
not run over if you run over like if you
get to the point where you're like
thirty seconds over we will come up and
remove you from stage and while I'm
preparing and while I'm rehearsing one
of the things that made me most stressed
out is that my finish times were really
variable and like 30 40 percent of the
time I ran over then other times I would
run two minutes under but miss something
really really important yeah so I was
brushing it yeah good god this is just a
crapshoot
like I am at the craps table with my
timing and that really was was a concern
for me so that was another element that
made had unique for me was that degree
of cutoff yeah I felt that way too and I
did end up going over by over a minute
good for you
and there it is and they were just like
we cannot we cannot stop this
performance I want to say also for
anybody who is listening and who is
right now in the grip of this kind of
fear and isn't sure whether they can
really get past it also like what is
waiting for you on the other side of it
is so gigantic because there's just
there's something weird about public
speaking where it has such
disproportionate value to in a way what
you're investing in it you know like
you're going up on stage for 18 minutes
or 40 minutes or whatever or maybe
within your own workplace you know even
giving a two-minute talk suddenly
everybody is regarding you as a leader
and as someone who they can turn to in a
new way from if you hadn't been willing
to put yourself forward in that way
definitely definitely I mean there's
there's public speaking as the force
multiplier yeah for the value of your
other skills which is absolutely true
and then public speaking in a way is
also a a wonderful diagnostic tool and
what I mean by that is I remember
talking to a friend of mine who
he's a wealth manager for a lot of
muckety-mucks who you would recognize
and he said I know them generally better
than therapists they've been seeing for
a decade within the first few hours
because money brings up everything that
talking about money it brings up the
full spectrum of someone's insecurities
fears desires neuroses sex also true and
public speaking I think if it makes you
remotely nervous when you start to learn
the public speaking liked it at least
for me it kind of bring brings up all
your stuff so if you're simply
interested in personal growth it brings
to the surface many different many
different pieces of your personality and
psyche that you can then work on in a
way that transfers to other areas so
that to me it was my experience and I
find really interesting ok well maybe
you don't have to play hide and go seek
with talk therapy for 20 years to find
all of the bits and pieces when if
rather than following these different
ginger betrayals you can use certain
fearful circumstances to just bring it
all right or a lot of it to the surface
that was my experience I'm not saying
it's true for everybody but it was one
of those things like talking about money
talking about sex or public speaking so
okay now we just bring we just bring
everything to the forefront so for me
that was that was also uh even if I even
if I had not had any interest in getting
on stage and giving presentations yeah
it would have been valuable yeah in and
of itself
ya know that makes complete sense are
there other things that you're fearful
of er have been afraid of that you've
overcome no I mean that was really the
big one for me
um but yeah we were talking about this
before I guess you know my Bugaboo in
general is that I just tend to be a
worrier so I don't know I other than the
experiences I had with public speaking
it's not like I have full-on panic or
anything like that
it's more like it's a very familiar
companion for me so I've had to just
come up with various hacks around it
what what are some of your hacks this is
gonna get us into another big topic but
uh but why not what of so for example
when I stopped practicing corporate law
and I decided that I wanted to be a
writer I told myself that it's really
hard to make a living as a writer and I
said okay the goal is to publish
something by the time you're 75 and at
the time I was 33 at the time that I
said that and I kind of did that
instinctively because I was always doing
these hacks of like just wanting to
completely take the pressure off of
something that I otherwise loved so
deeply and like I just knew that if I
turned this thing that I deeply loved
into a source of like this has to be the
place where I make my my living this has
to be the place where I derive some kind
of professional stature it was gonna
soak a lot of the joy out of it and so
that's the kind of hack that I just
naturally do so on a very related note
could you give us a little bit of
context around the leaving law like why
you left law and then you decide you
want to be a writer and you kind of
alluded to it but does that mean that
suddenly your rent is dependant on
writing right okay so I had wanted to be
a writer from the time I was four and
then you know for a whole bunch of
reasons and like so many people I
graduated college I took some creative
writing classes in college and I decided
you know I'm not actually that good at
this and I need to make a living and I
also kind of had a desire I think to
show myself that I could be out there is
a kind of alpha person out in the world
of finance or something so I went to law
school and I and I practice law at Wall
Street law for almost a decade and and
during that time that I was practicing
law it was so all-consuming that
completely forgot about the fact that I
had wanted to be a writer it wasn't like
you know I was walking around conscious
of this broken dream or something like
I'd completely forgotten and in the
first few years of practicing law I
really loved it it was just this kind of
crazy adventure that I was on and as the
years went by it started to get really
tough for me you know I'm not a very
natural lawyer in a million different
ways but I was on this partner track and
I was committed to it and and then came
the day and I think I may have told you
about this in an earlier correspondence
but then came the day when a senior
partner in my firm walked in and said I
was supposed to be up for partner that
year and he said well we're not going to
be putting you up and funny thing is to
this day I don't really know if he meant
we're not putting you up ever for
partner or just not anytime soon I don't
really know what it meant all I knew was
like number one I burst into tears and
number two here was my
get-out-of-jail-free card
so three hours later I had left the firm
like I was gone I took a leave of
absence and I just started bicycling
around Central Park like I didn't know
what I was going to do next but as soon
as that space opened up that I now had
free time for the first time in like ten
years I started writing and I had no
idea that was gonna happen
it was almost like in a movie that's
cool yes I've just been waiting for you
yeah literally I like I remember that
night you know like kind of curled up on
my sofa in my apartment and I just
started writing on my laptop and um and
then a week later I signed up for a
class in creative nonfiction at NYU and
I just had this complete feeling of
certainty that this was what I wanted to
be doing and zero expectation that I
would make a living out of it so so and
this this is a really important thing I
think I think if you have that kind of a
creative dream and a creative love you
have to do everything you can not to
spoil it
the pressures of paying the rent and all
those those other things or the
pressures of needing to derive
professional status from it so I set up
a little side business teaching people
negotiation skills and that was how I
was paying the rent but the thing I was
really doing in my heart was this
beloved hobby of writing this is this is
super super super super super important
and there are it's I think it's true in
creative fields which is pretty much
every field but just for the sake of
illustration writing music etc that also
an entrepreneurship you hear these
stories of desperation where a necessity
is the mother of invention and you know
but a Bing but a boom magic wand and
then there's a billion dollar company or
there's JK rowling or whatever it is
yeah
but those are in my experience the
outliers at those they make for great
cover stories and magazines but the fact
of the matter is that from what I've
seen certainly with with guests on this
podcast is that for instance soman
chainani who has a number of mega
successful novels but he had a SAT prep
counseling service that he offered well
past the point that his first book was
successful because he wanted to always
feel like he had a safety net yes so
that the writing would not be tainted or
even subconsciously influenced to match
the market or whatever the the lens
might become by this pressure yeah and
that is something that whenever possible
has come up as a really valuable I
suppose of one-hand financial sort of
survival mechanism but even more so a
psychological the freeing device yeah
yeah and you know I think we're so
addicted to having a really glamorous
narrative for things and the glamorous
narrative is you know you you you had so
much courage you took the risk you know
you you were depend
this company or this book or whatever
and if it didn't work it was gonna be a
disaster but you know you you were the
one who beat the odds like we love that
narrative and for most people that's a
really bankrupt narrative and there's a
kind of deeper glamour actually in in in
the kind of story that you just told
yeah because you're because the glamour
comes from your you're doing everything
that you can to deeply protect the thing
that you love most definitely now the
book itself people may not may not know
backstory I'm sure a lot of people don't
how long did it take to get that book
done okay so I'm laughing because I took
a really really long time especially by
Tim Ferriss standards look at your life
trajectory like how does he do that but
lots of cheating with format is the
short answer
so yeah took from start to finish it was
about seven years and I will say in my
defense that during those seven years I
also had two children and was raising
them so that was part of it but I also
just think I'm kind of a slow writer
like I like to really really think about
everything super deeply and what I think
is probably people might not know I had
a deadline as all writers do and I
turned in some sort of draft upon my
deadline coming to you you know after 18
months or two years right and my editor
basically read it and said this is
terrible she said you know go back and
completely throw that out start from
scratch and take all the time that you
need and and you might think that when
that happened that I would have been
really bummed but I was actually like
elated because I knew that it was
terrible and I knew that I needed much
more time and I had no idea what I was
doing I'd never written anything before
so yeah I was just really happy to have
that time and it's actually really
unusual like usually in publishing they
had given me a big advance or the book
and usually
they want their advance back and they're
not willing to delay like that so that
was he's very understanding editor
yeah she's brilliant and I'm working
with her again on my next book yeah
that's it it's all so smart and in the
sense that I think I'm a mediocre book
is more of a liability than notebook at
all yes right yeah for everyone involved
for everyone involved yeah and because
you know I have this philosophy about
writing that it's the the deep love that
has to be protected at all costs because
of that I don't care how much time it
takes you know like I'm just interested
in doing it as well as I can what is
your what is your writing process at
this point look like so you've you had
your experience with that book and now
when you are writing do you have a daily
practice does it go through phases of
research period then organizing then
putting all of that into prose through
synthesis what is what is your what are
your writing routines or how do you
think about writing these days so for me
I take whatever thesis and working with
and then I spend a year or two just
walking around the world looking at
everything through the lens of that
thesis you know so it used to be
introverts and now it's a on to a new
topic and I'm taking crazy notes through
that period so we have a conversation
that I have every book I read it's all
going in how do you how do you take and
organize your notes do you do that
notebooks do you do it digitally what
are the I know tha's nerdy but I know
I'm into it because a lot of writers do
it differently the reason I'm laughing
is I'm thinking when you hear my answer
you're gonna know that I need a
consultation with you I don't do it in
in a super systemic way I am I basically
all those conversations all those ideas
and notes and thoughts I'm having I
stick them all into one word document
and then I go and that document becomes
about seven or eight hundred pages by
the time I'm done
and then I go through that document and
I and I'm kind of tagging as I go along
and then I'm separating everything out
by topic so I end up with like eight or
nine loose-leaf binders that mm-hmm are
organized by topic but in each of those
binders it's just like one big one big
or massive notes and then I think about
where do I want everything I don't and
also whenever I write whenever I have an
idea um like whenever I'm emotionally
moved by one of the ideas that I'm
taking notes on I try to write out the
riff around that idea right then and
there because you don't know if that
emotions gonna come back so you have to
capture it when it happens I think it's
perfectly fine system so you feel like
technology must have come up with
something better like I do it in
Microsoft Word I heard there are
probably better tools available but I
would say also that a lot of people
confuse new tools for better content
people it's very easy
at least let speak for myself for a
second when I'm writing I have to
disallow myself from thinking about say
marketing because marketing is fun and
exciting and to you easy for me because
I've ever had insomnia is a kid watched
mini infomercials or something in any
case that takes it's a it's a way to
procrastinate doing the harder piece
which is the actual research and digging
in Proust that's the hard part for me
always has been but it's the most
important part and I think similarly a
lot of folks get can become consumed by
upgrading their tools multiplying their
tools versus just the words you got to
put the words in and the I have some
questions about this word doc though so
when you're going through and adding
things to the word doc and you come in
and you're tagging things so you can
separate them and you mentioned binders
so you're printing the stuff out and
then separating them does that mean that
when you put in a new note in the word
doc you go to a new page if it's tagged
differently so you can separate them
more easily later does that make sense
as opposed to each time you add a note
then hit return twice and then add a new
note if they're tagged differently it
would seem like you would have to cut up
the page into multiple pieces so do you
start a new page are there any
particular ways that you tag for instant
would it be a chapter name or would it
be a theme what would would the tag yeah
a topic or a theme and yeah so every
time I'm adding a new note if I know
that it relates to something I've
already done then I'll search for the
thing I've already done so I can add it
to that section make sense but you know
sometimes I don't or I can't think of it
and then I'll just add it to the end of
the document oh yes which control-f
right word yeah yeah good to go yeah
simple simple works Robert Rodriguez the
filmmaker keeps a journal I think he
does puts it in almost every day at
midnight and it's word doc or ducks yep
it works yeah yeah I actually I will say
I tried for this next book I spent a few
days reading the instructions for
Scrivener one of these program critters
and I just ended up thinking you know
this isn't for me it looks great
Scrivener well some other time we can
sit down that that that is one tool that
if you if you set it up really simply
and you don't use 98 percent of the
features I find really useful just
because you can create a view by which
you see all of your separate documents
or actually I should say rather you see
your tentative table of contents on the
left side in a in a vertical pane and
then you can look at what you're on the
right-hand side then I would have it set
up so that I have to to split windows so
the left hand side you see your table of
contents and then there's a research and
then you have whatever research you want
that way you can be working on a
document in the upper right hand pane
while you have your research that you're
ringing off of in the bottom right and
if you decide to move Doc's around to
see how it effects flow it's just
drag-and-drop
it's it's actually quite quite wonderful
they did have some issues with footnotes
or maybe I was just too technically
incompetent
at one point we knew that had to export
when the publisher insists on say word
which maybe that'll chance at some point
but getting a little a little geeked out
but the Scrivener I've you skipper
dinner for almost all of my books there
may be one exception I think for our
chef because of how visually intensive
it was it was done outside of that and
in terms of routine or ritual you spend
a year gathering these notes so then you
have see yeah or more so you have 700 to
800 pages it's a big word doc yeah and
then what happens yeah so then I spend
the time sorting them out and so I get
to the point where I've got my eight or
nine loose-leaf binders that are more or
less organized by what the chapters are
gonna be yeah and then comes the time to
write during which I'm still doing more
research but I'm starting to write and
yeah for me the writing like the sitting
down with my laptop and thinking about
it all that's like I want to say it's my
happy place but that's not really the
best description it feels like it's this
place that I go deep in my mind and I
really love being there and it's like no
matter what happens to be going on in my
outside life I always have those few
hours a day where I'm going to a cafe or
a library or whatever and I'm sitting
with my laptop and my cappuccino and I'm
just doing it and like I'm stressing the
emotional aspect because that's so huge
for me and I feel like I train myself to
associate writing with all of these
pleasures of you know sitting around in
cafes and things like that
what is the do you have a consistent
time when you sit down with your
cappuccino and do this are you a morning
writer or you a catch-as-catch-can
writer are you evening writer I mean you
also have kids you have other
obligations so when do you when do you
tend to do your writing or do your best
writing you can answer it however you
like well I mean there's what I do and
there's what would be ideal but as you
say I have kids so my routine is that
I dropped my kids off at school that's
at around 8:00 then I go and I either
play tennis or do yoga every day and
then after that I do my writing and
that's a pretty good time for me but
what time of day would that typically
anything
yeah that probably ends up being around
10:00 or so that I'm starting yeah but
you know if I had no other obligations
the best times of day would be more like
either 7:00 in the morning and also
super late at night so two time periods
that I have no access to you for this
stage of life right but yeah and you
start writing this is this really
interesting to be hopefully interesting
to other people so you start let's say
around 10:00 do you break for lunch do
you skip lunch do you have a standard
type of lunch that you would have and
the reason I ask is that I think part of
the reason so many writers seem to work
between the hours of say let's make this
up but 10:00 p.m. and 7:30 a.m. yeah and
they tend to either be night owls like
me or early risers is that there are
fewer distractions and they get an onion
get it relatively uninterrupted block of
three to five hours if you're starting
at 10:00 then most people that have
lunch scheduled shortly thereafter
around like two hours later great so do
you break for lunch
do you have something really small how
do you how do you handle that just for
me just speaking personally it's a yeah
if yeah you might have time of course I
have time for a five minute phone call
but if I do a five minute phone call
about something very mechanical or
mundane like calendaring stuff or
whatever and I'm juggling 15 pieces that
were on paper in my head I kind of have
to start over a lot of times like I drop
all those balls right because of the
task switching yes I'd love to hear not
that that's true for everybody but it's
true for me so what what is what does
your schedule look like then once you
sit down
I'll just kind of go until I realize
that I'm not concentrating well anymore
and very often that happens after two or
three hours and I just have to take a
break like I actually I have a lot of
discipline if my brain would cooperate
like so I would happily sit there for
seven hours until my kids come home from
school but at a certain point I'll
notice that it's just not coming anymore
yeah yeah and so then I'll take a break
and I'll eat or something like that but
you know I would say like you were
mentioning well people might work at
night because it's when you get
uninterrupted time and I think that
that's one factor but I also think the
reason that those hours tend to be so
good so nighttime is when your cortisol
levels are really low you know which of
course is your stress hormone and so I
noticed this in myself all the time that
the ideas that I come up with late at
night are different from the daytime
ideas they're completely unfettered by
any stress and so I'll just I don't know
I just make different kinds of
associated leaps and there's there's
like a softness and an ease in my
thinking and my feeling about the ideas
so I think like that's one image of late
night writing and then in the morning
you've got the high cortisol but you
also have this sort of acute attention
yeah so I can totally do that I can
definitely see that I also find that
writing late at night if I'm writing at
2:00 in the morning it's a very hard for
me I remember I want to say it was ayan
Rand who wrote she had a book about the
craft of nonfiction and there was some
it's not exactly it wasn't a metaphor I
think it was a real-world example but in
effect she's saying writers many writers
will do almost anything to not write and
there's the story about the white tennis
shoes like I have to clean my white
tennis shoes before before I'm gonna
write because I'm gonna go out and die
and when it's 2:00 or 3:00 in the
morning like I have to check email to
make sure X is just not a viable excuse
it also just removes a lot of [ __ ]
distraction that I would impose on
myself to avoid doing what it is that I
find
hard I still relate to this like what so
when I was writing quiet I suddenly
developed this idea that I had to learn
everything in the world about digital
photography and I was reading all these
books about it and the rule of thirds
and all this stuff and I have never had
any interest in photography before or
since it was just these two weeks of
mania where I didn't want to have to be
looking at that manuscript over there
are there any are there any any
particular I mean you are student of the
craft right you've taken creative
nonfiction courses are there any
particular books or resources or writers
who have had a significant impact on how
you view or practice writing oh gosh I'm
sure the answer is yes um and I can I
can try to buy some time too I can if
helpful I mean I draft number four by
John McPhee I think this is really I was
very fortunate just to spend time with
him when I was an undergrad in college
because he was teaching us the structure
took my creative writing right yeah so
the structure the structure thinking
about structure in the way that McPhee
thinks about structure saved me because
I thrive with some type of predetermined
blueprint for stretcher it's very hard
for me to just freehand flow of
consciousness let things take some
emergent form it's very hard I do know
friends who who do that really really
well that terrifies me so I need the
scaffolding right right bird by bird by
n I love that book yeah it's a good prep
bird by birds for people who don't know
the book I will say just before getting
into a short description has saved at
least a half a dozen friends of mine
from the precipice meaning they were at
the point of throwing in the towel and
just quitting their books and there they
were all writers in this case but they
were it you're at the point where
they're like I'm done I can't do this
it's too stressful I don't like this I
don't want to do
it's gonna be terrible and they were
going to in some cases return their
advances and just walk and I want to say
at least half of them read this book
went on to finish their books and their
books went on to become New York Times
bestsellers so talk about an important
window for making a decision and the the
gist of the book the title I should say
comes first from I think it was her
brother Anne's brother and Lamont as a
writer and her brother had this
experience we had had something like an
entire semester in the making this up
but let's just call it fourth grade to
prepare for this end of semester project
and he was supposed to put together a
term paper on birds or something like
that and it's like the night before end
in any preparation and this poor kid who
granted kind of deserves it because it
didn't do any prep but nonetheless is
having a second nervous breaking out the
kitchen table with like 15 books about
birds and he just is paralyzed and now I
say it was an end its dad who came over
and like put an arm on his shoulder and
said just take it bird by bird buddy
bird by bird something like that and
it's sort of a psychological life raft
break glass in case of emergency kit for
writers who are just hitting that point
like maybe you did with the photography
we were just like I want to do anything
other than look at that screen or that
page I just I can't handle it and I
don't know what to do so for that reason
not necessarily for the the nuts and
bolts of the writing process itself but
for the psychological component it's
like if you had a hey if you were a top
athletic coach and you had your sport
specific technical coach and then you
had a mental toughness coach who also
doubled as a shrink like the mental
toughness coach who doubles as a shrink
is the bird by bird yeah and I'm
remembering she also talks about shitty
first draft yes I mean just those three
words are incredibly helpful because you
know when you're looking at your draft
and it is always really shitty at the
beginning and so just knowing okay
that's what it's supposed to be yeah but
yeah you know the other thing that's
been really helpful to me
so I told you I started taking that
creative nonfiction class at NYU and the
student all of us who took that class
got along really well so we formed a
writers group after the class was
officially done and we stayed together
for years and we would meet once every
week every two weeks and read each
other's stuff and especially at that
stage that really really helped you know
getting the feedback but also having the
kind of camaraderie and support system
not totally isolated yet feeling
isolated and I actually met my literary
agent from one of the people who was in
that group who was a publishing lawyer
and I said you know I have this idea for
this book about introverts which at the
time to me seemed like the most
idiosyncratic project on earth but she
said when you're ready I know the right
agent for that yeah and and that's a
really serendipitous thing because wait
I want to share this when I put together
the proposal for the book that became
quiet I sent it out to that agent who
she recommended and to four other super
amazing agents two of whom I had
connections to and every single one of
the other ones passed and some of them
said you know I really like the writing
but I think this topic is not commercial
enough and I just don't think it'll sell
so could you come back with a different
topic and and and and Maya the guy who
became my agent instantly saw what the
potential was going to be and we've been
together ever since and I feel like I
owe him everything and I love him
his name is Richard pine if you were out
there looking for an agent and I think
about this story all the time not only
because of book writing but because all
these people these other agents you know
these are experts and these are the
culturally anointed gatekeepers and they
know what they're doing and yet they
didn't see this one particular thing and
I think that that happens all the time
totally so no I'm glad you shared that
and I had very similar experience I
reached out to I want to say was four
agents who were introduced by a very
successful author who I'd met something
like seven years earlier
by volunteering at a non-profit which is
a great way to meet people above your
paygrade
as a sidenote just like filling water
glasses for panelists it works really
well and so I had the right introduction
the writing I didn't think my writing
was Tolstoy or anything but it was it
was passable and complete rejection
pretty good before it was before our
word before our work week two of them
were not we're pretty heavy-handed about
it the one of the third July I remember
name Gillian Manus a very good agent and
she passed but she gave me a lot of
really helpful feedback and she didn't
say this won't work she just said I
don't think this is the right fit for me
right and that one fair enough it's just
totally fair yeah but like yeah here's a
bunch of advice and one of the pieces
she gave me actually Wow I haven't
thought about this forever
was think of each I was intimidated by
the prospect of writing a book I never
written a book before she said treat
each chapter like a feature magazine
article beginning middle and end
self-sufficient yeah each chapter can
live on its own and I've followed that
advice
ever since yes with a nonfiction yeah
which makes it easier to write also
because if you get stuck somewhere you
don't it's not like you have to cross
that bridge to get to a chapter that
sequentially should show up three
chapters later you can treat it in a
modular way right if you get really
bogged down you can skip which also in
some cases like the rest of my books
leads to a book that can being read not
sequentially in any case and I so it's a
three out of four turn it down
finally sign with my current agent
Steven Hanselman who I still work with
to this day there's similarly yeah and
he had just become an agent Wow
he had just become an agent but part of
what attracted me to him was that he had
a long career as a very successful
editor and was also is just an eclectic
guy went to Divinity School plays in a
jazz band and really went like Mike
my kind of person yeah and then we went
out to sell it and things like to always
forget if it's like 26 or 27 but
nonetheless or something like 27 or 28
somewhere between 26 and 28 publishers
turn it down
really yes and then the but you only
need one that's the thing it's like you
it's not about how many people don't get
it yeah it's about having the right
person or people who do get it and I
mean which just is so clear with your
book right it's like you don't need all
the people in the world to think it's a
good idea you don't need half the people
in the world thing it's good idea you
need the people who it resonates with to
have it resonate yeah that's it and it
does not need to be does not need to be
millions of people it could be but it
doesn't have to be and I want to I had a
note down also to just and we don't have
to necessarily a ton of time on this but
just to clarify the talk about
introversion versus shyness and so I and
I came across this when I was doing good
homework which is people think of say
Bill Gates right it's sort of maybe a
one example of someone who could be
useful in distinguishing between the two
but could you clarify what an introvert
is how you define introvert yeah from
from somebody who's shy right yeah so
introversion is really about kind of
about the the preference for lower
stimulation environments and you can
trace it to your neurobiology is like
introverts have nervous systems that
react more to all the incoming stimuli
and so that means that we're kind of at
our most alive and happiest and switched
on when things are a little more chill
around us which is probably why when
you're in those group dinners you're
going to the restroom every so often
because your nervous system wants to
tone it down and extroverts have the
opposite situation and the opposite
liability and because for an extrovert
you've got a nervous system that's
reacting less to stimulation and that
means when you're in an environment that
you find too quiet
you start to get really listless and
checked out so that's the liability
their shyness and and I always feel like
I my work has to do with both
introversion and shyness by the way but
but shyness is much more about the fear
of social judgement so you'll know if
you're a shy person because when you
when you encounter someone who has a
neutral expression on their face you
will have a tendency to read disapproval
in their and to react really strongly to
the disapproval like you feel kind of
really unhorsed by it and and it can
take different forms so it could be a
fear of public speaking or it could be a
job interview or any kind of situation
where you feel you might be evaluated so
in reality
lots of introverts do tend to be shy and
vice versa but not necessarily at all um
I don't know Bill Gates personally but
my guess is that he's an introvert but
not specially shy and then somebody like
an Eileen Fisher who you know she's got
this wonderful and I think it's been
decades now super successful fashion
brand she describes herself as a shy
extrovert so like she really wants to be
around people all the time she wants to
be connecting all the time you talk to
her she's she's constantly like setting
up this workshop and that program and
you know you look at her life and she's
always surrounded by lots of people and
things going on but she's often feeling
intense discomfort and needing to work
through that boiled yeah yeah it's it's
I would I would certainly describe
myself as an introvert and I never knew
quite how to frame it until coming
across your definition of preferring
lower stimulation or environments or
environments with with fewer stimuli and
because I've ever since I was a little
kid been very sensitive I mean my sight
is very sensitive right my hearing is
very sensitive yeah but I'm not shy in
the sense that I don't
I want to engage and ask questions and
interact but if the volume is turned up
too much are there too many speakers
metaphorically or visiting I have a lot
of difficulty parsing at all but you
don't have like shyness would be like
you know before you go into those group
dinners are you feeling a kind of social
anxiety no right that's the difference
yeah yeah yeah there are so many
questions that I want to explore but
let's set because we have maybe maybe 10
or 15 minutes more let's ask a few of
the questions that I that I always like
to ask sure are there any books that you
have given the most to others as a gift
or any books you've gifted often to
other people I think that the book I've
probably for the last few years been
giving out the most is waking up by Sam
Harris which it's fantastic it's such a
fantastic book and it was really for me
completely life-changing I think for
probably the reasons it is for many
people which is I hadn't really known
much about meditation before reading it
and because and I'm Kay you know I think
by my my nature I'm sort of a cross
between a skeptic and a mystic or
something yeah you know skeptical side
of me and it's a pretty deep skeptical
side it really needed somebody like Sam
who's such an extreme skeptic right um
you know and then who very conveniently
spent like what 28 years of his life or
something in investigating all these
different spiritual tools and then
reporting back on them you know for me
that was a narrator I could really I
felt I could really rely on mm-hmm
fantastic book you know I just I have to
I suppose I think you'll we were talking
a bit about Sam before we started
recording because we were we were both
you know sort of fanboying and
fangirling about the this meditation app
and a handful of other things but I
haven't told you and I don't know if I
even mention
this publicly about here we go so the
first time I met Sam this relates to Ted
went to Ted for the first time as an
attendee which by the way was too much
stimulation so I never went back
but I'm interesting yeah but I went to
Ted the first time as an attendee and I
was invited to one of these group
dinners great and so I go out to this
group dinner and we're eating dinner and
off to the side on a separate table
there's this tray of brownies and I love
brightness it's one of my weaknesses it
is an Achilles heel and I have zero
portion control and these brownies are
large brownies and I I sneak over kind
of in between courses and I'm like you
know what I'm gonna skip one of the
later courses and just substitute the
brownest cuz I love brownies and so I
eat two of these brownies and about 20
minutes later the hosts do I shall not
name him comes up to me he goes Tim did
you eat any of the brownies okay I had
two of them and he goes okay
everything's gonna be fine and I'm like
wait everything is gonna be fine
what the hell are you talking about they
were heavily dosed pot brownies and I am
NOT a habitual pot user and so I
suddenly in the middle of dinner just
get hit by this tsunami of cannabis and
you combine that with my discomfort with
high stimulation environments and I'm
like I need to get the hell out of here
so I excused myself to go to the
restroom and by this point I'm already a
huge fan of Sam yeah but I've never had
any contact with him so I run off to the
bathroom to escape and I opened the door
and literally like at the sink run
straight into Sam Harris in the men's
room like Sam Harris high off my rocker
and he looks at me kind of like it's
like huh that's kind of sideways cuz I'm
just just beyond reality at that point
and that was my first meeting Sam
hilarious did you tell him I did I did
I did tell him which he appreciated
because he does have he does have some
history with altered states but yeah I
know I I found that book and and the
subsequent meditation app and all of it
incredibly helpful and fantastic at you
know the one the one piece of it that
I'm kind of trying to explore separately
because I feel like he looks at much
less is the whole tradition of
loving-kindness meditation and all the
meditations around that so that's really
really of interest to me yeah and so I'm
sort of charting a different course
there and I'll tell you like even just
last night I was interviewing onstage
this guy Haman's unum I don't know if
you've heard of it he's a really
renowned Zen Buddhist monk from Korea
and his books are all number one
bestsellers in Korea and lots of other
countries but here he's less well-known
but anyway he has a new book out so I
was doing this interview and we're up on
stage so you can see the audience and it
happens to be a pretty formal audience
so before we start you know the audience
is kind of sitting there and if still in
their seats and then he opens by doing a
loving-kindness meditation and it was so
amazing to see the transformation on
their face on their faces and he did
this for maybe one or two or three
minutes like it wasn't long yeah and you
know suddenly they're totally smiling
and they're open and they're happy and
yeah it's remarkable yeah it's
remarkable and I think it's so weird and
dispiriting how in the mainstream media
and in corporate life there I mean it's
great that there's been this incredible
embrace of mindfulness meditation but I
think there's a kind of allergy towards
going too much in the loving kindness
direction um and I spoke to Sharon
Salzberg about this who's one of the
great teachers and and and she said that
people have this sense that it must be
phony
like that you couldn't possibly actually
have those feelings and so it kind of
gives them a sort of creepy feeling to
do it
totally but I feel like that all needs
to get completely rethought
lovingkindness the label I think smells
have kind of hand wavy hippy
associations and therefore people veer
away from it yeah or if they have
sensitivity to that stuff which I do and
have for a very long time but so
mindfulness for many years absolutely
they recast but I eventually met I
mentioned that as a contrast to my then
subsequent experience with
loving-kindness meditation also called
meta ma TT a meditation which I was
introduced to not first by jack
Kornfield that i did spend some time
with him who's sort of of the same
cohort as Sharon Salzberg they're close
friends and Sharon spent on the podcast
but mang Chad magton of Google actually
who started this class within Google
called I think it's search within
yourself it was a course included many
tools including mindfulness and he has a
book called joy on demand which is
fantastic I thought was a fantastic
title I was like I could use join demand
let's let's take a look at this and
there's a very short part in that book
which ended up excerpting for I want to
say tools of Titan's about
loving-kindness meditation and he tells
the story of this woman who as an
experiment guided or suggested by Meng
did a one-minute loving-kindness
meditation on the hour every hour for
one work day and she would and she would
pick people who were walking about the
office or so and she came back you said
that is the that is the best day I've
had at work in seven years Wow and I
think part of that is at least for me
that I am very historically been very
trapped in my head I'm very prefrontal
yeah and I come from a family of
warriors people who are warrior worrier
ah warriors not not not the battle axe
but but the like Larry David type right
and when you are consumed with worry
or anxiety and this is not my
description but it's been described to
me as being trapped in the future right
like depression is being jumped in the
past anxiety or worrying's being trapped
in the future and it's also at least for
me it's a focus on the self and say me
me me it's all things that might happen
to me things that I should do and the
loving-kindness meditation which can be
so short and have an impact gets you
unlike most types of mindfulness
practice that are popular or becoming
popular in the West it gets you out of
yourself yeah and I recall when I was
writing tools of titans I I decided to
take mags advice and I did
loving-kindness for literally two or
three minutes every night I was at this
hotel and they had a dry sauna and I go
into a dry sauna really late because I
was doing my writing really late right
and just do 2 to 3 minutes of thinking
about a friend and wishing them
happiness and seeing them smiling and
giving them a hug and having them smile
back at me and wishing me the same and
it was transformative as as regards with
regards to my mood it was really just
incredible yes
low dose really really low dose and I'm
curious you mentioned that you were
thinking about or meditating on
loving-kindness to your friend
did you also start with a traditional
practice of wishing it to yourself or is
that less comfortable if this is a great
question so I did not it did not even
occur to me to do this until years later
when I went to my first 7 day might have
been 10 day Sunday no 10 day silent
meditation retreat at spirit Rock great
and jack Kornfield was there yeah and I
went in they check in with you to make
sure you're not having a total psychotic
break for a few minutes every other day
and I had this meeting with Jack and and
one of his co teachers for the event and
we were talking about leaven kind of
talking about leaven kindness and as I
was leaving the woman with Jack said
just out of curiosity have you been
doing any loving-kindness for yourself
and it struck me I don't know how to
describe this in with doesn't look make
me look like an ass but it just struck
me as such a silly question I was like
now of course I haven't been doing it
for myself and then I realized how much
that probably explained a lot of my
problems and she goes yeah you might
want to try that when you experiment
with that and and remember Jack later
saying you know if I'm paraphrasing but
you know if your compassion doesn't
include yourself and it's incomplete
yeah and that is bad you can't really
give it to other people and it weighs
either right so that has become problem
I'm so glad you asked that one of the
biggest changes in my and I could call
it a mindfulness practice but my way of
relating to the world and thinking about
helping others has been actually taking
time to show or counter think on self
compassion specifically for myself at a
handful of younger ages yeah yeah which
I do at mealtimes
and am I talking about that more at some
point but yeah that's become really it's
become a very very very very important
ritual for me but I don't think you're
alone I mean Sharon Salzberg mentioned
to me that many people have trouble I
mean the traditional progression of the
practice would be start with yourself
and then you know move progressively
outward to other people in your life and
she said many people have trouble
beginning with themselves and so I was
really struck because last night um his
mom came and seen him who I love began
in this meditation by directing it to
ourselves and I asked him about that
afterwards and he seemed kind of puzzled
by the question which made me wonder if
this is a uniquely American problem I
don't know it reminds me of the story I
heard of this I don't know what it was
Nepalese or I know Bhutanese monka came
to the US and he he was in a car on the
way to some event and there are these it
was in the US and there are these people
running and you're jogging on the side
of the street to get in shape but
they're just they look like they were
dying
and looking they're running from hyenas
and he's just like are they okay what's
wrong with them my goodness so we've
just a few minutes let me ask you the
Billboard question so if you could put a
message on a billboard this is
metaphorically speaking to get a message
a quote a question anything
non-commercial out to millions or
billions of people what might you put on
that billboard I think I'd probably put
with one aphorism that I've loved since
high school I think which is only
connect by ianforster I only connect
only connect yeah like that at the end
of the day that's all that really
matters what does that mean to you it
just means connecting on some really
deep level with the people around you
and that might sound like an ironic
aphorism for someone who wrote a book
about introversion but to me those are
not contradictory things at all you know
and so for me like connection it can
happen in person for sure but it could
also happen just by listening to the
music music that's really touching you
and you feel completely connected to
this musician who may not even be alive
anymore you know or a writer who might
not be alive anymore but they're
expressing something deep and unchanging
about what it's like to be human so
those I think there's kind of nothing
more important than that only connect
only connect is there anything you've
done that has helped you to more deeply
or frequently experience those moments
or any advice you might have for people
who want to cultivate that well I mean
so aside from meditation which I am a
huge proponent of but I think you really
do have to pay attention to what works
for you and it really is so different
for everybody you know so for me I love
to have deep one-on-one conversations
it happens through music it happens
through literature and those that's how
it happens but I think it it really is a
different answer for every language
person but I'll tell you this is maybe a
different topic but the whole idea for
my next book came out of one of these
kinds of experiences which is I have
always had a love of bittersweet and
minor-key music and and the books not
about music but I'm gonna tell you this
story anyway okay so when I was in law
school I was listening to music like
that in my dorm and a friend came by and
he was kind of a funny wise guy yeah and
he said why are you listening to this
music to commit suicide to and you know
and I thought it was funny and I laughed
but I thought about it for decades
afterwards like I was thinking well why
is it first of all what is it about our
culture that makes this music so suspect
that you would make that kind of joke
and also what is it about the music
itself that for me is not suicide
inducing at all it's like it's the
opposite I feel when I hear music like
that completely connected to everything
because it's like the the the composer
is expressing some really deep truth
about what it is to be human and so
anyway so I thought about this for
decades and the place that I'm going
with this next book is that I think that
tuning into the sorrows of the world
actually is a kind of secret superpower
that we're not really allowed to access
very often because of course we live in
this culture that tells you you know
don't go there and always wear the
smiley face and so on but you know if I
can say like even look at somebody like
you even before you started being really
open and upfront about some of the
demons that you've struggled with which
by the way you know like all the honour
to you for doing that it's amazingly
brave and generous but even before you
did it and if you had never done it I
don't think you would have been touching
all those people the way you have all
these
if it weren't for those sorrows I agree
yeah yeah so it's all about that I'm
excited to read your next book
thank you I think it's a really really
really really important topic yeah I
think it's really important I think I'll
have to do round two in that case I
would love that
that would be awesome I just have to
write a little faster I I will happily
wait for your best work so in qiyam no
need to rush
well Susan this has been such a joy and
I'm sure people can hear it but just
just to maybe underscore the point I
mean you are very you're a very present
person when you're speaking with someone
else and I can see why you feel that in
the room and so you're walking the talk
which is always refreshing and not
always the case
thank you for taking the time today
thank you so much I really enjoyed it
yeah hang out and I will link to
everything in the show notes for folks
including the the name of the Korean
monk that I couldn't spell to save my
life
at the moment but we will have links to
everything at teamed-up blog forward
slash podcasting just search Susan and
pop right up people can find you online
presumably where are the best places to
to say hello learn more about what
you're up to
well best thing is to sign up for my
newsletter which you can get to you if
you go to quiet Rev comm which is
required evolution so you'll find it
right there on the home page there's a
sign-up form and there's a newsletter
that goes out every week so that's the
absolute best and then I'm also super
active on Linkedin and on Facebook great
is that simply Susan Cain because I
think Facebook prepare for wrong I think
is author Susan oh gosh thank you for
saying that yeah so on Facebook it's
author Susan Cain and unlinked in I
actually don't remember but it's part of
the LinkedIn influencer I'm sure if you
put in LinkedIn influencer and my name
it'll come right up yeah and then
Twitter may be less active yeah I am on
Twitter but a little less active but at
season pad Susan
yep and I can't wait to see the next
book and continue to follow your work
thank you so much I will say the same to
you what is the next book what is the
next book well you know based on the
episode that came out a few days ago I
think it's gonna be this book that I
have been waiting to give myself
permission to write which is about it's
not that it'll be a close cousin to what
you are thinking a lot about right now
it would be how to pay attention to the
psycho-emotional undercurrents and
components of life very closely and how
to use tools both on the beaten path and
off very very very off the beaten path
for finding a resolution for problems or
challenges or insecurities or trauma
that are at least in current
conventional practice considered very
difficult to treat or untreatable that
Wow so that would be as far as I can
tell and I've been gathering notes for
about five years now that would be that
would be the thrust of it that's gonna
be your most important book I hope so I
mean yeah yeah I hope so
what's your timetable what's my
timetable um
it's well as who was it I think this was
this is something I heard on a TV set
once they didn't want people to rush but
it was the the gist was people need to
rush and they said but they didn't want
to say that make people panic so they
said we need everyone to move with
purpose okay so I think my answer is
move with purpose mmm
but not in haste because I want to treat
it with the depth and thought that it
deserves I don't want to rush and we'll
probably write it without signing before
selling anything or signing any
contracts I'll probably
oh you'll write the whole thing I'll
probably do
on my own time Oh interesting okay but
it is it is a top if not the top
priority well so so are you like working
on it every day right now I am in some
fashion working on it every day but it's
going to be a while before I get to the
the composition prose stage but the vast
majority of the work that I do on my
books is the experimentation and the
traveling for subjecting myself to all
sorts of unusual things and the
note-taking and the organizing of said
notes right and I'm doing some piece of
that almost every day
well yeah oh I'm so glad you're doing
this book yeah so if I can help you know
if you want an early reader or whatever
I would love to also completely I alley
well likewise likewise this has been so
much fun and until until next time thank
you so much thank you so much and to
everybody listening same until next time
thank you for listening hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's four hour work week calm I'll
spell out and just drop in if your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
peloton have been using probably for
about a year now peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you can also do on-demand
which is what I do we'll come back to
that so you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into a busy schedule or
making it to a studio or gym with a
hectic or unpredictable commute I for
instance have a peloton bike right in my
master bedroom at home and it's one of
the first things I do many mornings I
wake up I meditate for a bit then I
knock out a short 20 minute ride in my
undies hard to do that at the gym take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's really convenient
and has become something that I look
forward to so you have a lot of options
for one if you'd like you can ride live
with thousands of other riders across
the country on an interactive
leaderboard to keep you motivated
there are also up to 14 new classes
added every day with more than 8,000
classes on demand and you can pick based
on length 45 minutes 20 minutes whatever
music hip hop rock and roll or say low
impact versus high intensity or interval
you can pick the class structure and
style that works for you and in my case
I quite like Matt Wilbur's and I tend to
do on-demand and listen to a lot of and
watch many of the same classes over and
over but I'm kind of promiscuous and
also enjoy classes from a lot of the
other instructors they have peloton an
amazing roster of incredible instructors
in New York City with a whole range of
styles and personalities so you can find
what you're in the mood for you also get
real-time metrics that you can use to
track your performance over time and
that will help I would say catalyzed you
to beat your personal best now that all
sounds good right
gamification yadda yadda yadda I didn't
think that it would work for me or in
any way incentivize me but they really
100% hit the nail on the head I was very
very impressed with how motivating it
was and it worked tremendously to keep
me pushing which quite honestly takes a
fair amount I can get quite lazy
particularly with anything that edges on
endurance which is kind of more than
five reps of anything for me so check it
out discover this cutting-edge indoor
cycling bike that brings a studio
experience right to your home peloton is
offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go
- one peloton calm that's PO and e
peloton PE l oto and calm and enter the
code Tim all caps at checkout and get
$100 off of accessories with your pals
on bike purchase so get a great workout
at home anytime you want check it out go
to one peloton calm and use the code Tim
to get started this episode of the Tim
Ferriss show is brought to you by linked
in the right hire can make a huge impact
on your business the wrong hire can
create your business and I have seen
example after example from thousands of
my readers at a minimum where they have
told these stories of how finding the
right person at the right time and in
some cases not even asking what should I
do
but asking who should I find because
that person can help me determine what
exactly to do more intelligently I've
had a chance to hire two such people in
the last year that has just made my
business take a quantum leap forward and
my complexity in my personal and
business life get cut dramatically in
this type of certification cannot be
overvalued we think a lot about hiring
and I think a lot about hiring and it is
a skill that I've had to work it is
important to find the right person but
where do you find that person you can
post a job on a job board and hope that
that right person finds your job that
they are on the internet happening to
scan something here and there and then
find you but think about it how often do
you hang out on job boards the answer is
probably not very often so don't leave
finding someone great to chance when you
can post your job exactly where people
go every day to make connections grow in
their careers and discover job
opportunities that is linked in most
LinkedIn members haven't recently
visited the top job boards but 9 out of
10 members are open to new opportunities
and with 70% of the US workforce
on LinkedIn posting there is the best
way to get your job opportunity in front
of more of the right people and you can
be very very highly targeted and
specific people who are qualified for
the role you have and ready for
something to do this is where you find
it it's the best way to find that person
that key person will help you grow your
business and this is why a new hire is
made every 20 seconds using LinkedIn
that's bonkers every 10 seconds so head
to linkedin.com pounce on Tim and get
$50 off the first job post that's a
linkedin.com forward slash tim TI m to
get $50 off your first jobless link
10.com forward slash tim take a look
terms and conditions
[Applause]
you